la séance est reprise
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale visant à faire
évoluer la formation de sage-femme
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à Madame Agnès Firmin le Baudot
ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé
la ministre c'est à vous
normalement
vous avez la parole très bien
madame la présidente madame la
Présidente de la Commission madame a
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs votre assemblée se prononce
cet après-midi sur une proposition de
loi inscrite à l'ordre du jour du Sénat
à l'initiative du groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoires le
gouvernement accueille favorablement la
mise à l'ordre du jour de cette
proposition de loi elle est le fruit
vous le savez d'une initiative
parlementaire à l'Assemblée nationale
sous la précédente législature le groupe
agir ensemble à l'Assemblée nationale
qui était le mien avait défendu cette
proposition visant à mieux reconnaître
les spécificités de la profession des
sages-femmes alors qu'elle joue un rôle
essentiel dans l'accès à l'offre de
premier recours
je tiens d'ailleurs à souligner
l'implication de l'Ordre des
sages-femmes aux côtés de l'ensemble des
ordres réunis dans le cadre du Clio
santé dans la signature la signature le
mercredi 12 octobre dernier d'un accord
proposant des solutions concrètes en
matière d'accès à la santé pour nos
concitoyens
face à la situation d'urgence que nous
connaissons cet accord apporte des
solutions inédites en vue de libérer du
temps médical et répondre aux besoins
des Français dans tous les territoires
grâce au développement de
l'interprofessionnalité le fruit de ce
travail collectif constitue une avancée
majeure elle s'inscrit pleinement dans
la démarche de leur fondation engagée
par François Braun et moi-même dans le
cadre du CNR santé lancé au moins le 3
octobre dernier
parmi les propositions des ordres
figurent l'amélioration de
l'attractivité des professions de santé
il s'agit de mieux valoriser les
compétences des professionnels de santé
au travers de leur formation initiale et
continues il s'agit aussi de garantir
une démographie des professionnels de
santé cohérentes avec les besoins de la
population
c'est en effet une nécessité et cette
proposition de loi constitue une partie
de la réponse elle constitue en effet un
nouveau pain vers l'intégration
universitaire de la formation initiale
des sages-femmes l'incus l'inclusion des
formations paramédicales et de
maiotiques dans l'université permettra
le développement de la recherche par
exemple en sciences infirmières en
réadaptation et en maiotique l'objectif
c'est que tous les étudiants en santé
apprennent ta coopérer dès les bancs de
l'université et bénéficient des mêmes
droits et des mêmes services que les
étudiants inscrits dans un cursus LMD
nous avons avancé sur ce sujet même s'il
reste encore du chemin à parcourir
depuis la loi du 21 juillet 2009 la
transformation en particulier de
plusieurs facultés de médecine en
faculté de santé à accélérer les
rapprochements avec les écoles de
maïotique la loi d'organisation et de
transformation du système de santé du 24
juillet 2019 a ouvert la voie à des
expérimentations en la matière et
relancer le processus d'intégration
universitaire des écoles de maïeutiques
la création d'une section du Conseil
national des universités en 2019
constitue une étape supplémentaire dans
le renforcement du caractère
universitaire de la formation
une mission relative à
l'universitarisation des formations en
santé en lien avec les services des
ministères de la santé et de
l'enseignement supérieur sera
prochainement confiée aux professeur
Christine Amirati et l'Inspection
Générale de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche sera également mandaté
sur ce sujet
la création d'un statut de maître de
stage universitaire en maillotique
prévue par l'article indice se constitue
une réponse au besoin d'encadrement des
étudiantes et des étudiants il est
essentiel cependant que ce statut fasse
l'objet d'un travail plus large à des
fins d'harmonisation avec les autres
professions en ce sens un groupe de
travail relatif à la maîtrise de stage
universitaire associant les acteurs de
la formation et les représentants des
étudiants et employeurs sera lancés cet
automne par la DGOS
la rédaction du troisième alinéa de cet
article sur la formation du maître de
stage universitaire a pu susciter des
interrogations au sein de la communauté
universitaire nous travaillons sur ce
sujet en lien étroit avec la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
je tiens ici à dissiper les éventuelles
inquiétudes les conditions d'agrément
des sages-femmes sont renvoyés à un
décret en Conseil d'État et même si la
rédaction actuelle précise une formation
obligatoire auprès de l'université ou de
tout autre organisme habilité il ne
s'agit pas en réalité d'élargir au-delà
des centres de formation actuelle
votre commission l'avait d'ailleurs
utilement souligné lors de vos débats en
commission la rédaction prévue par
l'article le premier bis reprend les
dispositions de l'article L
41-316 du code de la santé publique qui
concerne la filière de médecine en
cohérence dans le cadre de
l'élargissement de la maîtrise de stage
universitaire à la filière de maiotique
il est plus adapté de maintenir ce
dispositif
le code de la santé publique a été
modifié par la loi ots du 24 juillet
2019 pour permettre au delà des
organismes habilités par l'Agence
nationale du développement professionnel
continu aux universités de former des
praticiens agréés maître de stage des
universités au final ce sont bien les
universités qui donneront les agréments
au mètre de stage universitaire
j'en viens à la création d'une troisième
cycle d'étude de maïeutique prévue par
cette proposition de loi vous le savez
les missions des sages-femmes ont été
progressivement élargies depuis 2009
elle couvre désormais de suivi de
prévention et de contraception des
femmes tout au long de leur vie tant en
ville qu'à l'hôpital le suivi de la
santé de la femme le suivi des femmes
avant et après leur accouchement c'est
par ailleurs ouvert sur une prise en
charge en ville cette nouvelle mission
justifie une adaptation de la formation
initiale
le Gouvernement soutiendra la
proposition de loi dans sa version
issue des travaux de votre commission
par amendement de Madame la rapporteur
la commission des affaires sociales a
choisi de reporter l'entrée en vigueur
de la réforme à la rentrée universitaire
2024 c'est à dire aux étudiants entrants
en année de passlas à la rentrée
universitaire 2023 le Gouvernement
partage pleinement cette analyse le
maintien du dispositif actuel aurait
conduit à embarquer dans la réforme les
étudements les étudiants actuellement en
deuxième année et troisième année de
premier cycle il était judicieux de
décaler son entrée en vigueur pour gérer
dans de bonnes conditions
l'harmonisation des différents cycles de
formation entre eux la préparation des
terrains de stage supplémentaires et
l'impact de la nuit blanche en 2028
le Gouvernement soutiendra cette
proposition de loi d'ailleurs saluée par
les représentants de la profession à
l'issue de son examen à l'Assemblée
nationale elle avait fait l'objet d'un
soutien unanime des députés je formule
le vœu qu'il en soit de même au Sénat je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Raymonde pont
Simon pour rapporteur d'un commission
des affaires sociales et pour 10 minutes
je reconnais
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues la proposition de loi
que nous examinons a été adopté à
l'unanimité par l'Assemblée nationale en
novembre dernier comme en commission des
affaires sociales au Sénat le 5 octobre
merci pour les femmes cette phrase
lancée par des sages-femmes lors de la
dernière audition signe l'attente forte
de la profession quant à l'adoption de
ce texte visant à faire évoluer la
profession de sage-femme et cette phrase
nous leur adressons en retour merci au
sage-femmes les sages-femmes ce sont
après de 97% des femmes mobilisées pour
la santé des femmes lors des auditions à
de nombreuses reprises une question a
été posée par des sages-femmes mais
pourquoi si peu de considérations et la
question se prolongeait est-ce parce que
nous sommes des femmes qui prononcent
soin les femmes le chant de compétences
des sages-femmes est le plus important
d'Europe et n'a cessé de s'étendre ces
dernières années la France reconnaît
depuis plus de deux siècles caractères
médical de la maïeutique et confie au
sage-femmes des responsabilités plus
importantes qu'ailleurs en opérant un
accompagnement global des femmes et des
familles les sages-femmes pratiquent un
métier du faire du prendre soin connu
pour leur présence en salle de naissance
elles effectuent aussi la surveillance
gynécologique je suis vie prénatal
postnatal celui du nouveau-né et ce dans
la maîtrise de la frontière entre
physiologie et pathologique malgré ses
avancées majeures contribuant à ce soir
son rôle la profession vit actuellement
un profond mal-être elle a la conviction
depuis trop longtemps de ne pas être
reconnu et là exprimé ces derniers mois
à plusieurs reprises les conditions de
travail des sages-femmes à l'hôpital se
dégradent le taux d'encadrement y est
toujours fixé par des décrets de
périnatalité de 1998 qu'il serait temps
de réviser leur formation ne sait pas
adapté suffisamment et demeure établi
sur un modèle Hospitalier Régional
correspondant à celui des professions
paramédicales
leurs conditions de rémunération et leur
statut ne correspondent pas de la vie de
toutes les organisations représentatives
de la profession aux responsabilités
aujourd'hui exercées il faudrait que la
courbe des rémunérations reflète celle
de l'élargissement des compétences la
tractivité de la formation en maiotique
et à travers elle de la profession
semble d'ailleurs se dégrader à la
rentrée 2022 20% environ des places
offertes en deuxième année de maïeutique
sont restés vacantes les étudiantes font
état d'une formation incomplète dont
l'intensité serait pourtant bien
supérieure à celle d'autres formations
médicales 70% d'entre elles déclare
souffrir de symptômes dépressifs
or la profession de sage-femme à
l'hôpital comment ville est essentiel à
la santé des femmes et à la santé
publique partout sur le territoire à cet
égard le récent rapporte sur la santé
périnatale de santé publique France fait
état d'une situation préoccupante de la
santé périnatale de façon globale en
France et rappelle que l'état de santé
de la petite enfance et de l'enfance
conditionne la santé à l'âge adulte
c'est la présente proposition de loi ne
résoudra pas l'ensemble des difficultés
auxquelles la profession est confrontée
elle pose déjà le nom d'une meilleure
reconnaissance de la profession ainsi la
proposition de loi en tant en premier
lieu renforcer le caractère
universitaire de la formation maïeutique
l'article premier visa achever
l'intégration universitaire des
formations de sage-femme initié par le
législateur il y a plus de 13 ans ce
processus est aujourd'hui à l'arrêt
d'après le ministère seulement 14 écoles
des 35 écoles de sages-femmes sont
intégrés à l'université la majorité des
écoles d'abord donc adossé un centre
hospitalier ce modèle qui correspond à
celui des formations paramédicales n'est
pas adapté à la profession de sage-femme
il ne favorise pas notamment le
développement de la recherche en
maiotique c'est pourquoi le texte que
nous examinons substitue à la Faculté
d'intégration une obligation assortie
d'un délai l'intégration des écoles de
sage-femmes à l'université devra être
achevée au 1er septembre 2027 ce délai
nous semble nécessaire en regard des
nombreux obstacles y compris en termes
de rémunération qui localement ont
souvent entravé le processus
d'intégration la loi fixe également les
modalités de cette intégration les
écoles de sage-femme seront intégrées
préférentiellement c'est important aux
unités de formation et de recherche en
santé mixte réunissant donc plusieurs
protection médicale seulement et
seulement quand cela n'est pas possible
elles seront intégrées aux UFR de
médecine ces dispositions soutenues par
l'ensemble des organisations de
sage-femmes auditionnées permettent de
préserver l'autonomie pédagogique et de
gouvernance des écoles de sage-femme
tout en favorisant la nécessaire
collaboration entre professions
médicales interdépendantes
la maïeutique n'est-ce pas l'art de
faire accoucher les esprits afin
d'encourager le recrutement
d'enseignants chercheurs dans la
discipline l'article 3 vise par ailleurs
à faciliter la conciliation des
activités d'enseignement et de recherche
avec le maintien d'une activité clinique
qu'elle soit ambulatoire ou à l'hôpital
contrairement aux autres professions
médicales les sages-femmes de
bénéficient pas aujourd'hui la statue
leur permettant de cumuler ces activités
malgré l'ouverture en 2019 d'une section
maïeutique par le Conseil national des
universités le recrutement de
sage-femmes enseignant de chercheurs
reste marginal au milieu de cette année
notre pays comptait une professeure des
universités on dit quelquefois une
deuxième est en cours et quelques
dizaines de mètres de conférence la
recherche en maiotique et peu développée
alors même que la France compte parmi
les pays où la formation est la plus
longue et où la profession exerce le
plus de responsabilité
la proposition de loi vise en deuxième
lieu à renouveler profondément le
contenu de la formation des sages-femmes
pour l'adapter aux mutations de la
profession elle crée cela a été dit un
statut de sage-femme agréé mère de stage
des universités inspiré de celui
existant pour les médecins généralistes
ce statut permettra de mieux encadrer
les stages en ambulatoire et
d'accompagner leur développement en
cohérence avec les nouvelles conditions
d'exercice de la profession le
gouvernement doit cependant réfléchir à
la manière de mieux encadrer également
les stages à l'hôpital les personnes
auditionnées l'ont fréquemment décrit
comme un terrain de stage difficile et
on regrettait le manque de valorisation
dans la loi de la fonction de référent à
l'hôpital surtout l'article 2 de la
proposition de loi réforme en profondeur
le contenu de la formation il crée un
troisième cycle d'études de maïeutique
lors d'une audition une sage-femme
soulignait enfin un troisième site comme
pour les autres professions médicales
parallèlement une révision de l'ensemble
des référentiels de formation est
également prévu et nécessaire les
étudiantes obtiendront désormais à
l'issue de leurs études et après
soutenant d'une tasse d'exercice un
diplôme d'état de docteur en maillotine
cette mesure soutenue par l'ensemble des
organisations de sage-femmes que nous
avons additionnées réduira l'intensité
d'études jugée trop dense enrichira leur
contenu pour mieux tenir compte des
nouvelles compétences confiées à la
profession comme de la diversification
des modes d'exercice elle favorisera
nettement le développement de la
recherche
enfin cette proposition de loi vise à
conforter la reconnaissance des
sages-femmes comme profession médicale
le quatrième article invite à modifier
la classification des sages-femmes dans
deux nomenclatures de l'Insee la
statistique est elle aussi traversée par
le genre bien plus qu'un miroir est
participe à créer des catégories nombre
de sages-femmes auditionnés sont
réjouissent car selon les mots d'une
d'une d'entre elles c'est un peu notre
histoire c'est un peu l'histoire de
notre vie de ne pas être dans la bonne
case si la Commission a approuvé ces
dispositions elle a toutefois modifié
leur modalités d'application le texte
imposait la réforme aux étudiants
actuellement en deuxième et troisième
année d'études qui sont qui se sont
engagés dans cette filière sans savoir
que celle-ci serait allongée mais
surtout elle ne pèse cette échéancier ne
permettait pas d'assurer la cohérence du
cursus pour tenir des inquiétudes des
étudiants comme des enseignants la
Commission a adopter deux amendements
visant à remporter la réforme à la
rentrée universitaire 2024 et à ne
l'appliquer qu'aux étudiants qui
entreront à compter de cette date en
deuxième année ce report facilitera la
gestion de l'année blanche sans sortie
de sage-femme diplômée que la réforme
générale
nécessairement ce soit qu'il permettent
également d'établir les nouveaux
référentiels de formation en
concertation large avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes
en conclusion ce texte est à la fois
nécessaire et urgent à cet égard
j'aurais souhaité vous proposer mes
chers collègues son adoption en termes
identique à ceux de l'Assemblée
nationale afin qu'il puisse entrer en
vigueur le plus rapidement possible mais
si les inquiétudes partagées relatives
au calendrier nous ont conduit mon
conduite à proposer à la Commission des
années des affaires sociales de le
modifier se souhaitent toutefois que ce
texte soit rapidement mis à l'ordre du
jour de l'Assemblée nationale en votant
cette proposition de loi nous répondons
à la huitième proposition du Livre blanc
des sages-femmes massychologue à la
naissance d'une trajectoire se trouve la
formation alors oui
pour leur reconnaissance l'attractivité
de leur vie
[Applaudissements]
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Madame else Joseph pour
le groupe les républicains et pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
même la présidence madame la ministre
mes chers collègues est-ce que vous
savez pourquoi on dit sage-femme non pas
parce que la femme est sage mais parce
que c'est une personne qui connaît les
femmes donc ça c'est donc messieurs que
l'on peut être homme et sage-femme le
texte qui nous est proposé est une bonne
nouvelle pour les sages-femmes c'est non
seulement la reprise des propositions de
Ligas sur leur formation mais c'est
d'abord et avant tout la prise en compte
d'une revendication légitime forme une
et depuis des années par celles et ceux
qui exercent un des plus beaux métiers
du monde et surtout une profession dont
les missions ont évolué et qui vont
désormais de la déclaration de grossesse
au suivi post-natal et hors du champ de
la grossesse avec un pouvoir de
diagnostic et un droit de prescription
élargie
les sages-femmes assurent des
responsabilités médicales dans un cadre
limité à leur métier alors compétences
et peuvent répondre à tous les actes
lorsque la mer est en bonne santé une
profession plus que jamais
incontournable le législateur a enfin
tenu parole par rapport à un combat mené
sur tous les bancs du Parlement loin de
l'image d'Épinal la profession de
sage-femme est profondément exigeante
elle suppose une formation longue qui
sera intégrée à l'université après nos
débats elle concerne la naissance mais
aussi l'avant et l'après
comme certaines professions liées à la
santé la profession de sage-femme mérite
d'être honorée d'un parcours
universitaire cela est logique par
rapport à nos politiques de santé
publique et à notre souci d'un
enseignement universitaire cohérent pour
cette raison je me réjouis de cette
université que ce soit dans les yeux et
faire de santé ou même dans une
composante de formation en médecine
parce que c'est une formation longue
j'approuve la mise en place d'un
doctorat qui pourra couronner ce
parcours universitaire dans cette même
logique j'approuve la création d'un
troisième cycle d'études pour les
étudiants en maiotiques c'est en effet
rapproché le parcours d'une sage-femme
des autres matières enseignées qui font
toute l'objet d'un troisième cycle cela
est également logique à une époque où la
spécialisation et dans tous les parcours
d'études
enfin cette proposition de loi tient
compte des impératifs propres à ceux qui
enseignent ils pourront exercer
conjointement des activités de soins de
recherche d'enseignement c'est aussi un
aspect important que l'on retrouve
notamment en médecine car il est
difficile de dissocier la théorie de la
pratique surtout dans les domaines de la
naissance
en raison de cette proximité il est
aussi pertinente qu'un statut de maître
de stage universitaire en maiotique soit
définie cela participe d'un
accompagnement optimal des étudiants
pendant leur stage mais cette
reconnaissance d'un statut universitaire
n'est pas la seule avancée de cette
proposition de loi tant attendue le
texte modifie la place des sages-femmes
dans la nomenclature de l'Insee je me
réjouis de les voir classer dans le
groupe activités des médecins et des
dentistes et non plus dans autre
activité pour la santé humaine et donc
dans cet entre deux qui fragilise leur
positionnement
vous l'aurez compris nous sommes dans
une situation qui n'est pas éloignée de
la médecine faire de la sage-femme un
acteur de référence pour la prévention
la santé gynécologique des femmes doit
être une priorité et c'est urgent c'est
une juste reconnaissance
tous ces dispositifs doivent rendre la
profession plus attractive donnez plus
de visibilité en repensant les carrières
encourageant les vocations et c'est
nécessaire comme en témoigne la pénurie
dans les hôpitaux
ce métier connaît une crise profonde qui
s'est traduite par de fortes
mobilisations début 2021 sont beaucoup
déco car les sages-femmes sont peu
nombreuses mais c'est amélioration que
je salue et que je vous invite à
approuver doit être accompagnée d'autres
progressions en particulier en termes de
statut et de rémunération pourquoi ne
pas aller non plus vers un statut de
praticien hospitalier certes les
conditions d'études seront améliorées
mais il ne faut pas oublier les
conditions d'exercice tout court de
cette profession c'est une profession
jeune et il faut investir dans cette
filière où les résultats sont bons
comme pour d'autres professions nous
avons besoin d'être plus attractif pour
les sages-femmes dans les zones rurales
dans le périurbain une femme doit
pouvoir accoucher au plus près de ce
lieu de vie et en sécurité elles sont
pour le gouvernement en exemple alors
madame la ministre que vous mettez en
place des IPA et que nous connaissons
les résistances qu'il peut y avoir les
sages-femmes par leur pratique et leur
histoire éclaire le chemin au lieu
d'ignorer les demandes des sages-femmes
ces dernières années c'est l'inverse
qu'il fallait faire les écouter et en
faire un exemple leur compétences dans
le domaine de la santé gynécologique de
l'IVG médicamenteuse de l'IVG
instrumental et expérimentale
actuellement les sages-femmes permettent
au quotidien l'accès à des soins
essentiels en augmentant leur champ de
compétences on trouve ainsi une réponse
à un sujet démographique médicale
préoccupant les sages-femmes attendent
ceci depuis longtemps des nouvelles
perspectives ont ainsi souffrir en
termes de recherche et d'exercices du
métier les sages-femmes sont
indispensables à la santé des femmes on
a besoin de leur expertise et c'est le
cas en particulier
en termes de détection des violences
sexuelles de maltraitance dans la
famille et de détection des personnes
vulnérables n'oublions pas ce rôle
social que je voulais sage-femmes nous
ne sommes qu'au milieu du gué il reste
encore beaucoup à faire pour les
sages-femmes et pour les personnes qui
bénéficient de leur collègues me réjouit
de voir tout le monde y compris le
gouvernement soutenir les sages-femmes
merci beaucoup merci
je suis désolé hein je vais mettre du
temps si on finit pas 20h40 le texte il
sera revu à une date ultérieure allez on
va faire attention maintenant on est
bien c'est bon mais je me permets de
rappeler cela à chacun d'entre vous la
parole est à madame Colette mélo pour le
groupe les indépendants et pour 4
minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
madame la rapporteur mes chers collègues
nous sage-femmes joue un rôle majeur
dans notre société celui de permettre de
donner la vie un rôle essentiel au
moment de la grossesse de l'accouchement
et du suivi posnatal n'oublions pas
qu'elle réalise 80% des accouchements
dit normaux en France malgré le fait que
chacun s'accorde sur leur importance
pour les familles ainsi que dans le
secteur de la santé la profession est
plutôt mal reconnue ce qui est paradoxal
alors que leur champ de compétences ne
cesse de s'accroître et tout
naturellement leur revendications le
métier évolue continuellement important
toujours plus de sécurité pour les
parturientes et leur bébé je tiens à
saluer les auteurs de cette PPL qui a
déjà été adopté à l'unanimité à
l'Assemblée nationale signe s'il en
fallait du sujet crucial que nous
examinons
je remercie le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire pour
son inscription au sein de sa niche
parlementaire la PPL a également été
votée à l'unanimité par les membres de
la commission des affaires sociales et
je remercie notre rapporteur pour le
travail effectué afin de permettre une
application très prochaine de ces
nouveaux dispositifs les 5 articles que
contient cette PPL constituent une
véritable réforme il vise purement et
simplement à supprimer le flou autour de
la profession sur son appartenance au
secteur médical ou au secteur
paramédical avec la création du diplôme
d'état de docteur en maiotique proposé
par la PPL ce flux n'a plus lieu d'être
les sages-femmes sont insérés au sein du
statut médical cette formation fera
désormais partie des formations
médicales et universitaires cela répond
à la revendication principale des
sages-femmes et je me réjouis de cette
avancée c'est essentiel pour la
formation bien sûr mais également pour
l'attractivité de la la rémunération
mais aussi l'offre et la qualité des
soins prodigués je tiens à encourager le
développement de cette formation sur
tous nos territoires nous sommes
nombreux dans cette émission à savoir
combien il est important d'avoir des
offres de formation implantées sur
l'ensemble de l'hexagone les étudiantes
et étudiants restent généralement dans
les villes où ils ont étudié il
renforçant l'offre de soins à l'heure où
l'on évoque de manière récurrente les
déserts médicaux cette pratique pourrait
contribuer à des avancées significatives
dans ce domaine c'est pourquoi je me
félicite également de la création du
statut de sage-femme agréée maîtres de
stage des universités
l'accompagnement des étudiantes et
étudiants et gâchent d'une formation
complète et de professionnels compétents
bien sûr tout essentiel qu'elle est
cette PPL ne sera pas suffisante elle
apporte cependant une solution adéquate
à la situation actuelle clarifier le
statut de sage-femme doit être
appréhendé comme la première étape d'une
réforme plus profonde
je pense d'ailleurs que cette réforme
doit être plus globale et concerner
l'ensemble de notre système de santé il
a déjà bien évolué mais les dernières
années nous ont montré que des
changements doivent être déployés pour
cela nous devons poursuivre nos
réflexions et ajouter aux avancées des
recharges réalisés des nouveaux progrès
le groupe Les Indépendants conscients de
l'importance de cette PPL et des
améliorations qu'elle a engendrera
votera en faveur de ce texte merci merci
chers collègues la parole est à Madame
Monique de Marco pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire pour
4 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues cette proposition de
loi a été adoptée il y a près d'un an
l'Assemblée nationale le groupe
écologiste sous la dérouté territoires a
souhaité l'inscrire à l'autre du jour
pour aider une profession en souffrance
et de les études
en 2018 déjà l'Association nationale des
étudiants sages-femme relevés que 70%
des sages-femmes en formation présente
des symptômes dépressifs et que 27% sont
vus a quitter la profession
malgré ces signaux d'alerte peu de
choses ont été faites pour répondre à
cette détresse en juillet 2021 un
rapport de Liga se relançait la question
de l'intégration du cursus de sage-femme
à l'université une circulaire de 2012
fixait le même objectif
elle n'a jamais été appliquée
nous avons conscience du contexte
dégradé d'exercice pour les sages-femmes
placés désormais sous l'autorité de
médecins obstétricien et dans un
contexte budgétaire hospitalier contre
dans le même temps le rapport de notre
société ananalité a évolué avec la
baisse du taux de fécondité et les
exigences des patients en fin l'ensemble
du corps médical se sont accrues
la détérioration des conditions
d'exercice des personnes accompagnant
les maires dans leur grossesse et
l'accouchement n'a pas été prise à bras
le corps
nous cherchons aujourd'hui à apporter
une première pierre à l'édifice dans la
revalorisation de cette profession
essentielle à la vie nous voulons leur
dire ici toute notre confiance
la santé des femmes et celle des
sages-femmes vont de pair l'histoire
nous montre d'ailleurs que la
valorisation de cette fonction autrefois
confiée à des matrons sans formation a
toujours améliorer la prise en charge
des patientes et des nouveaux-nés
la professionnalisation est de
renforcement du matériel pédagogique
sous l'impulsion de personnalité
ingénieuse comme Angélique de Coudray au
18e siècle ont contribué à faire chuter
la mortalité des nouveaux-nés et des
mers elle avait créé un petit mannequin
pour expliquer les matelas obstétricales
cette proposition de loi répond donc
sans ambiguïté aux besoins de
revalorisation du métier de sage-femme
par exemple avec l'intégration
universitaire de l'ensemble des écoles
de sage-femme d'ici 2027 également avec
la création du titre de docteur en mai
en facilitant ensuite la possibilité
pour les sages-femmes de pouvoir
enseigner faire de la recherche tout en
maintenant une activité clinique et
enfin par la reconnaissance de la
nomenclature Insee de la profession de
sages-femme comme médical et non
paramédical au même titre que les
médecins et les dentistes il s'agit
d'une demande de longue date de la
profession
le texte ne répond pas à toutes les
attentes et notamment aux espérances en
matière de rémunération
madame la ministre notre geste
parlementaire de revalorisation
universitaire devra se doubler d'un
geste du gouvernement pour une
ruralisation budgétaire
pour un exercice apaisé de la profession
d'autres changements doivent intervenir
je pense notamment au statut de
sage-femme référente portée par le
groupe écologiste solidarité territoire
en 2021 lors de l'examen de la loi
visant l'amélioration de la santé par la
confiance
et nous attendons toujours la
publication du décret pour que cette
nouvelle disposition puisse rentrer en
vigueur
grâce à l'initiative d'enny-sapelier
donc je salue la présence en tribune et
au travail de Raymond de pensée mange
dans son rôle de rapporteur nous
espérons que cette proposition de loi
puisse rapidement entrer en vigueur et
dans les meilleures conditions je
souhaite que notre chambre puisse faire
preuve de sagesse transpartisanes en lui
apportant un soutien unanime comme à
l'Assemblée nationale et en commission
des affaires sociales je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Xavier yakovelli pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant et pour 4
minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur chers collègues la
profession de sage-femmes a
progressivement évolué elle a évolué du
point de vue de la reconnaissance
nécessaire et celle-ci a toujours fait
l'objet de combat de cris d'alerte de
mobilisation de ces femmes et ses hommes
qui tiennent souvent nos enfants avant
nous
elle a évolué surtout du point de vue de
leur compétences de leur mission qui se
sont largement renforcés au fil du temps
notamment dans le domaine de
l'obstétrique et de la périnatalité
elles se sont par ailleurs élargies en
matière de gynécologie depuis les années
2000 leur mission sont essentielles
puisque les sages-femmes suivent en
toute autonomie une patiente de la
déclaration de la grossesse jusqu'à la
réalisation des soins postnataux du
nouveau-né et de la mer ainsi que la
révélation de certaines vaccinations
elles peuvent également conduire
l'entretien prénatal précoce qui est
fondamental pour préparer l'arrivée d'un
nouveau-né et des bien sûr les parents
et les futurs parents à le devenir et
dissiper les doutes et questionnements
qui peuvent peser sur sur eux dans cette
période particulière la loi du 21
juillet 2009 à par ailleurs élargi leur
champ de compétences sous réserve de
suivi de formation elles peuvent
désormais réaliser des échographies
gynécologiques des actes d'ostéopathie
prescrire des contratsceptifs hormonaux
ou encore poser des dispositifs
contraceptifs sous-cutanés conduire des
consultations de contraception et de
suivi gynécologiques dans une logique de
prévention auprès des femmes enfin en
2021 elles peuvent depuis 2021 pardon
elles peuvent prescrire certains
médicaments et des arrêts de travail
sont limitation de durée pourtant ces
évolutions majeures ne se sont pas
accompagnées d'une reconnaissance
croissante de leur métier et c'est bien
là dont il s'agit car le nombre
d'étudiants sage-femmes n'a jamais cessé
d'être de baisser et il est jamais été
aussi bas avec 20% de place vacantes
pour cette année universitaire malgré
l'action du gouvernement qui avait acté
une augmentation du nombre de places de
1,5% par rapport à 2020 le constat est
alarmant chers collègues sur 1000
sages-femmes 40% quitte la profession
dans les deux ans qui suivent
l'obtention de leur diplôme face à cette
pénurie du au décalage client entre les
niveaux de responsabilité et la
reconnaissance dont elle bénéficie le
gouvernement a apporté des réponses
concrètes afin renforcer l'attractivité
du métier je pense bien sûr à la
revalorisation financière de 500 euros
net par mois en moyenne pour les
sages-femmes hospitalières je pense
également à la prolongation du
doublement du taux de promu promouvable
dans la fonction publique hospitalière
sur la période 2022-2024 il s'agit là
d'un engagement inédit du gouvernement
puisque l'ensemble de ces mesures de
revalorisation représentent 100 millions
d'euros en 2022 par ailleurs la création
d'un entretien post-natal précoce
obligatoire et les campagnes
d'information visant à promouvoir les
compétences des sages-femmes confiées à
la CNAM dans le cadre du dernier PLSS
traduisent la reconnaissance de l'État
envers celle et ceux qui œuvrent aux
côtés des parents et des nouveaux-nés à
cet égard la proposition de loi que nous
examinons visant à faire évoluer la
formation des sages-femmes comporte des
dispositions intéressantes que nous
saluons puisqu'elles vont dans le sens
d'une meilleure reconnaissance du métier
elle permettra de renforcer la qualité
de la formation en créant un diplôme
d'état du docteur en maillotique et pour
rendre systématiquement l'organisation
de la formation initiale des
sages-femmes au sein des universités
elle crée également un statut de maître
de stage universitaire pour mieux
accompagner les étudiants et créer un
troisième cycle d'études pour les
étudiantes en Haïti conformément à
l'engagement du gouvernement afin de
leur permettre de découvrir les
différents modes d'exercices sur le
territoire leur place consolidée dans la
démocratie statistique permettra de
reconnaître davantage le caractère
médical de la pro de la promotion ce que
bien sûr nous saluons cette proposition
de loi comporte d'autres dispositions
intéressantes puisque grâce à ce texte
les sages-femmes enseignants de
chercheuses pourront désormais exercer
une activité de soins en parallèle de
leur fonction d'enseignement et de
recherche pour toutes ces raisons et je
viens d'en évoquer plusieurs notre
groupe ou votre favorablement pour cette
proposition merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Emilienne
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains et pour six minutes chers
collègues
la présidente madame la ministre madame
la rapporteur même la présidente de la
commission chers collègues je tiens tout
d'abord à remercier le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire et la
rapporteur même vraiment de penser mange
d'avoir mis ce débat l'ordre du jour de
notre rassemblée aujourd'hui ce texte
très attendu par les sages-femmes sera
je l'espère l'occasion de faire entendre
leur voix et de porter la reconnaissance
et la volatorisation que la profession
de sage-femme mérite au fil du temps
avec la médicalisation et la
technicisation croissante des
accouchements les sages-femmes ont vu
leur rôle évoluer leurs compétences
s'élargir mais leur statut lui est resté
inchangé en effet alors que le code vase
santé publique reconnaît le métier de
sage-femme comme une profession médicale
leurs actes ne sont que partiellement
reconnus dans les nomatures
cette situation est paradoxale car face
au manque de gynécologue sont
aujourd'hui devenus les relier les
piliers indispensables du parcours de
santé de la femme ainsi depuis plusieurs
années exercent de nouvelles activités
en dehors du centre traditionnel de la
grossesse tel que le suivi gynécologique
la prescription de contraceptif la
pratique de l'IVG la préparation à
l'assistance médicale à procréation
ainsi que la prévention et l'éducation à
la sexualité
c'est enrichissement des compétences des
sages-femmes nécessairement conduit à
augmenter la densité de leur formation
initiale qu'à aujourd'hui comme trop
dense et bien supérieur à celle des
autres professions médicales en effet
les études de sage-femme comme un volume
supérieur de 1246 heures par rapport à
d'autres formations médicales qui durent
au minimum 6 ans cette intensité des
études ni au bien-être étudiant et à
l'attractivité des études en maiotique
et selon la nef en 2018 plus des deux
tiers d'étudiants de la maudite soufrés
de symptômes dépressifs
face à ces constats il était
indispensable de réformer la formation
des tests des sages-femmes et à cet
égard la présente proportion de loi
consacre des avancées que nous saluons
dans un article premier le texte établit
la nécessité de parachever l'intégration
universitaire des sages-femmes afin de
lutter contre les inégalités entre les
différentes écoles puisque aujourd'hui
sur 35 écoles 24 fonctionnent encore
selon une régulation et un financement
régional tandis que 11 ont opté pour un
financement universitaire ce qui crée
une disparité préjudiciable à titre
d'exemple dans certaines icônes les
financements régionaux n'ont pas évolué
et la réforme du numerus apertus
effectuait l'année dernière n'a pas pu
être mise en œuvre donc le nombre de
places information pour les sages-femmes
n'a pas augmenté au contraire en donnant
aux universités la compétence d'agrès et
de financer des écoles starticle premier
renforce ainsi le statut médical des
sages-femmes la création de statut de
sage-femme agréé maître de stage des
universités au même titre que pour les
médecins généralistes par l'article
indice représente une avancée importante
dans l'encadrement des étudiants et dans
la valorisation de la fonction
d'encadrement message
l'article 2 en consacrant la mise en
place d'un troisième cycle universitaire
répond à une demande forte de la
profession et le groupe cerf qui
soutiennent depuis longtemps cette
mesure se félicite de sa mise en oeuvre
dès la rentrée 2024 et nous avons
expliqué pourquoi nous regrettons
néanmoins que renforcement de la
formation continue des sages-femmes en
passant de deux et demi à 15 jours par
an comme demande les syndicats et
l'ordre ne sont pas prévus dans ce texte
autre mesure pour renforcer notre
activité de la profession c'est
l'article 3 qui prévoit la possibilité
donc au doctorante d'affiliaire
maïeutique d'exercer simultanément leur
activité professionnelle et des
activités des enseignement et de
recherche enfin dans son article 4 la
présente proposition de loi reconnaît
l'activité de sage-femme comme une
activité de pratique médicale au sein de
la nomenclature ce qui était important
des activités françaises de l'Insee
cette mesure répond à une demande
récurrente de la profession et met fin à
une situation injustifiée eu ég
ou à leur activité mes chers collègues
donc ces propositions de loi adopter
cela a été dit à l'unanimité par
l'Assemblée nationale présente de réels
avancées pour la reconnaissance de la
profession de sages-femme et le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain la
soutiennentra
néanmoins la réforme de la formation ne
représente qu'une partie de la réponse à
apporter aux sentiments de déclassement
des sages-femmes et aux besoins
d'attractivité de la profession depuis
de nombreux mois les sages-femmes
alertes les pouvoirs publics sur leurs
conditions de travail et face au silence
des pouvoirs publics elles ont manifesté
et elles ont fait grève ainsi des
questions de rémunération qui sont
encore en deçà des autres professions
médicales les questions des conditions
de travail loin du modèle une sage-femme
tel que mise en place certaines de nos
voisins européens
un enfant du manque de personnel la
révision des décrets de vitalité devront
faire l'objet de prochaines textes
aujourd'hui une sage-femme est amenée à
prendre en charge jusqu'à trois patients
de par garde du 12 heures en salle de
naissance et 25 patientes ensuite de
couches dans ce ton contexte il paraît
difficile pour les sages-femmes d'avoir
assez de temps pour accompagner
correctement tous les couples qu'elles
doivent suivre
les conditions de travail dégradées ont
des conséquences sur la santé mentale
des sages-femmes et près de 40% d'entre
elles ont un burn-out en milieu
hospitalier le métier de sage-femme est
tellement perte d'actrice d'attractivité
qu'on enregistrait en France près de 20%
de postes vacants je me permets donc de
vous interpeller madame la ministre sur
la nécessité d'un texte plus large sur
la périnatalité et sur l'accompagnement
de la santé des femmes et des
nouveaux-nés dans la lignée je dirais du
rapport sur les mines premiers jours un
texte d'autant plus nécessaire que
l'Agence nationale de santé publique
dans ce rapport du 20 septembre sur la
santé périnatale note de grandes
inégalités territoriales avec une
situation qui s'est aggravée cette
dégradation inquiétante
merci beaucoup merci la parole est à
Madame Laurence Cohen pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je remercie à mon
tour le groupe écologiste et ça
rapporter Raymond de ponts et Monge
d'avoir repris un texte adopté à
l'unanimité à l'Assemblée nationale
visant à faire évoluer la formation des
sages-femmes en France les sages-femmes
sont 23400 et prennent en charge chaque
année plus de 750 000 femmes qui
accouchent et autant de nouveaux-nés
elles assurent la surveillance le suivi
médical de la grossesse prépare à la
naissance à la parentalité cette
proposition de loi vise donc à
moderniser la formation des sages-femmes
en parachevant l'intégration
universitaire de leur formation d'une
part en créant un troisième cycle
d'études en facilitant la recherche en
maïeutique et d'autre part en
réaffirmant le statut médical du métier
de sage-femme depuis de nombreuses
années les étudiantes en maillotique
ainsi que la communauté des sages-femmes
militent pour l'intégration
universitaire des études de sage-femme
parmi la profession médicale celle des
sages-femmes est la seule dans la
formation n'est pas intégralement
assurée par les universités cette
situation entraîne de fortes disparités
sur le territoire selon une enquête de
l'association nationale des étudiants
sage-femmes réalisés en 2019 seul 16%
des écoles aurait mis en place des
référents de terrain pour les élèves
durant les stages la création d'un stage
de maître de stage univers d'un statut
pardon de maître de stage universitaire
prévu par le texte répond donc à une
attente forte des étudiantes les études
en maiotique comportent aujourd'hui un
volume horaire nettement supérieur aux
autres formations médicales qui
expliquent pour une part que cette
étudiantes sur dix présentent des
symptômes dépressifs la création d'un
troisième cycle d'études en maillotique
vise donc à alléger le volume horaire
des enseignements et à mettre en
cohérence la formation des sages-femmes
avec leurs compétences qui n'ont cessé
de s'étendre ces dernières années tant
en matière obstétrique gynécologique
pédiatrique qu'en matière de prévention
les constitue une profession de santé
aux conditions de travail dégradées à
qui l'on demande toujours plus sur le
plan médical sans que la reconnaissance
sur le plan statutaire et salarial
suivent on se souvient toutes et tous
ici de leur longue mobilisation pour se
faire entendre les gouvernements
successifs ont ajouté des compétences et
étendues les attributions des
sages-femmes sans compensation salariale
ni amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail et revalorisation leur
qualification comment expliquer que
cette profession médicale soit si mal
reconnue madame la ministre si ce n'est
peut-être parce qu'elle est exercée
quasi exclusivement par des femmes dans
la fonction publique hospitalière les
sages-femmes n'appartiennent pas à la
catégorie des personnels médicaux alors
qu'elles sont titulaires d'un diplôme de
niveau bac + 5 incluant une première
année de médecine elle commence entre
1600 et 1800 euros nets par mois et sont
exclus du bénéfice de diverses primes il
faudra donc continuer à légiférer pour
reconnaître le métier de sage-femme
améliorer leurs conditions de travail
revaloriser leur rémunération
contrairement gouvernement qui ajoute
une dixième année de médecine dans le
PLFSS 2023 sans discussion avec les
internes irréflexions sur leurs études
cette proposition de loi ajoute une
année d'études en prenant en compte le
rythme de la formation le contenu
pédagogique et les nouvelles compétences
des sages-femmes depuis de plus elle
autorise les enseignants de chercheuses
en maillotique à pouvoir cumuler la
recherche et leur activité clinique sans
possibilité de refus autant d'avancer je
note bien sûr que l'Association
nationale des étudiants sage-femmes
aurait voulu que le texte aille plus
loin en accordant un statut spécifique
permettant la bille appartenance
hospitalière et universitaire cette
proposition de loi ne répond pas
l'ensemble des revendications de la
profession mais elle constitue une
première étape et c'est important et je
pense à mon ami camarade le docteur Paul
Cesbron qui l'aurait salué lui le
militant infatigable de la
reconnaissance de cette profession comme
hautement médical en attendant donc et
bien les sénateurs et sénatrices du
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste voteront en faveur de cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie et
madame la Présidente je vous souhaite 8
secondes c'est parfait merci beaucoup la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Marie van
lorenberg pour le groupe Union centriste
et pour 6 minutes
pour madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur et chers
collègues qu'il est loin le temps des
accoucheuses voilà deux ans deux siècles
pardon que le législateur donne de plus
en plus de responsabilités au sage-femme
et à celle justement qui nous offre le
premier souffle de vie quitter le
domicile pour la maternité fut une
évolution dans la prise en charge
médicalisée de l'accouchement mais
l'exigence accrue de sécurité entraîna
la fermeture en 25 ans sont ces
maternités trop petites ou sans
obstétricien et au passage la
marginalisation des sages-femmes de son
de leur rôle le discrédit est
aujourd'hui tel que selon l'Association
nationale des étudiantes
à peine plus dans la moitié d'entre
elles penserait à exercer uniquement à
l'hôpital pire
la vacances de 20% des places ouvertes
cette année en formation souligne ce
désamour
la souffrance au seul stade de la
formation mais aussi dans les fonctions
professionnelles nous interpellent les
mouvements sociaux de l'année passée
nous l'ont très justement rappelé en
effet la barque des sages-femmes c'est
du chargée au fil du temps de nouvelles
responsabilités médicales mais qu'en
est-il de la reconnaissance le sentiment
exprimé par la profession est celui d'un
entre deux d'une zone grise qui ne
reconnaît pas leur travail à sa juste
valeur au fond je crois qu'on ne serait
dissocié la question du statut des sages
femmes de l'égalité entre les femmes et
des hommes mais nous ne pouvons plus les
laisser dans un statut qui ne correspond
pas à leur rôle dans notre système de
santé donc défendre les sages-femmes
c'est aussi défendre les femmes
le gouvernement a apporté une première
réponse et je la salue sur les salaires
le Parlement se charge aujourd'hui de la
question de la formation je me félicite
que cette proposition de loi madame la
rapporteur puisse appuyer une démarche
sur une démarche aussi consensuelle en
ce sens
l'article premier vise donc à valoriser
la formation initiale des sages-femmes
en posant les bases de son intégration
universitaire un chantier vieux d'une
décennie en décloisonnant les formations
en santé nous ne pourrons tendre vers
une plus grande égalité entre les
étudiants et je l'espère rendre cette
filière plus lisible et plus attractive
c'est aussi l'occasion de faire de la
pluridisciplinarité une richesse pour
notre système de santé pour ne plus
enfermer les acteurs dans une spécialité
où il sera difficile d'évoluer même de
sortir ceci fait écho à l'accord que
vous avez rappelé madame la ministre
dont je me réjouis qui vient de se
conclure entre les trois ordres l'ordre
des médecins des kinés des infirmiers
dans la continuité
l'article 2 vient quant à lui créer un
troisième cycle d'études réaffirmer les
connaissances physiologiques des
sages-femmes est nécessaire renforcer
leur discernement sur les situations
pathologiques en y associant bien sûr
l'apport des nouvelles technologies
l'est aussi
ce passage à bac + 6 est une avancée
dans le chantier de l'attractivité de ce
métier la rémunération résonnait déjà de
sa faiblesse à bac + 5 alors il faudra y
être encore un peu plus attentif
il s'agisse il s'agissant pardon de
formation l'article 3 permettra de
rompre avec l'inégalité une de plus
entre les sages-femmes et les médecins
pharmaciens ou chirurgiens dentiste
en autorisant les doctorants de la
filière maïeutique à exercer
simultanément leur activité
professionnelle avec la recherche
l'enseignement ce sont les sages-femmes
de demain qui gagneront l'article 4
enfin bien reconnaître l'activité de
sage-femme comme pratique médicale alors
que le code de la santé publique
considérait les sages-femmes comme une
profession médicale la nomenclature
enfin des activités françaises la
cantonais
au domaine paramédical cette évolution
est donc bienvenue
sur ces bases l'Union centriste votera
donc favorablement ce texte mais restera
aussi attentif que vous chers collègues
à ce que le premier pas en faveur de la
formation en la mettent plus franc sur
les conditions de travail merci beaucoup
de votre attention chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Stéphane Ravier
pour 3 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers
femmes vont mal nous en convenons tous
les mots de la profession sont connus
des salaires trop faibles commençant en
1700 euros net par mois après 5 et
peut-être bientôt 6 années d'études
sélectives un manque d'attractivité
alors qu'à la rentrée 2022 20% des
places en deuxième année d'étude sont
restés vacantes des études très intenses
alors que 70% des étudiants présentent
des symptômes dépressifs les
sous-effectifs chroniques qui font que
44% des sages-femmes ont déjà fait un
burn-out une sage-femme a toujours
plusieurs femmes plusieurs mères à gérer
en même temps alors qu'elle ne devrait
en avoir qu'une seule pour un suivi de
qualité car oui dans des plaises au
planning familial et aux idéologues
d'extrême gauche se sont bien les femmes
qui tombent enceintes et qui accouchent
et que l'on appelle maman et papa en
deux mais au-delà de ces chiffres
alarmants il y a une réalité qui
quantifiable toutes les sages-femmes que
j'ai rencontrées m'ont dit une chose
elle manque de reconnaissance qu'a fait
le gouvernement macronien depuis 5 ans
au mieux les ignorer au pire les
mépriser au début de la crise sanitaire
elles ont été tout bonnement oubliées
dans la distribution des masques
destinés à protéger les professionnels
de santé les syndicats de sage-femme ont
également été oubliés dans les
négociations du Ségur de la santé de
2020 aujourd'hui encore leur profession
n'est toujours pas reconnue comme
essentiel puisque sur une grande partie
du territoire elle ne fait pas partie
des métiers prioritaires pour accéder
aux stations essence c'est vexations
répétées ne sont peut-être rien pour
vous mais elles en disent beaucoup de la
considération dans laquelle cette
majorité les tient et surtout surtout
casser le gouvernement contre le manque
d'effectifs qui transforme leur journée
de travail en enfer comme les autres
professions médicales il a été décidé de
suspendre les sages-femmes non vaccinés
contre le covid-19 parce qu'elle
souhaitait disposer librement de leur
corps ces personnes ont été brutalement
humiliés alors où toutes les études
démontrent que ces vaccins n'empêchent
pas la transmission du virus il n'est
pas trop tard pour pour faire amende
honorable et revenir sur cette décision
aux yeux pallier dans manque d'effectif
est une urgence avant de prétendre
former de nouvelles sages-femmes ce qui
prendra 6 ans il faudrait commencer par
réintégrer celle qui le sont déjà en ce
mois d'Octobre Rose où nous alertons sur
les dangers des cancers du sein
rappelons que les sages-femmes sont des
interlocutrices de choix pour effectuer
des dépistages à ce titre aussi nous
devons les choyer cette proposition de
loi n'est certes pas dépourvue d'intérêt
et reprend certaines demandes de la
profession chez moi à Marseille
l'ensemble de la formation est déjà
intégré à l'université et cela
fonctionne mais plus que des mesurettes
c'est de reconnaissance j'insiste de
reconnaissance dans les stages de femmes
ont besoin afin qu'elle retrouve la
dignité liée à une profession
essentielle car une société qui ne sait
plus accueillir la vie est une
c'est magnifique
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame kylaine pantal
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen pour 4
minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur chers
bon nombre d'éléments pertinents ont été
évoqués par les orateurs précédents et
je ne m'y attarderai pas je souhaiterais
simplement souligner dans mes propos
introductifs l'importance du texte que
nous examinons aujourd'hui au Sénat
après son adoption à l'Assemblée
nationale le 25 septembre 2021
en effet au cours du premier confinement
au printemps 2020 la notion de
travailleurs essentiel a fait éruption
dans le débat public avec certes
quelques controverses sur le périmètre
que cela pouvait recouvrir mais avec un
large consensus autour de leur
nécessaire revalorisation
le secteur de la santé ayant été
nettement pour périsé ces dernières
décennies les professionnels comme les
sages-femmes en fait partie de ces
personnes
exerçantes à l'hôpital ou en libéral
identifié par nos concitoyens comme
n'étant pas suffisamment reconnu alors
juste mesure
à la suite d'un recueil de plusieurs
témoignages et notamment celui d'une
sage-femme un établissement de santé
privé d'intérêt collectif se déficit de
reconnaissance s'ajouter selon elle à
des stéréotypes sur la profession
consiste à les imaginer comme des douces
subalternes dans le rôle ne sursure pas
donc ce circonscrit à la participation
aux accouchements
or la moindre prise de recul nous
enseigne que c'est bien loin d'être leur
seule mission fondamentale et que
d'autres responsabilités tacites
viennent se greffer dans leur
quotidienne
c'est un grain de partie ce qui a motivé
des auteurs de cette proposition de loi
par l'étoffement de la formation de
sage-femme et son rapprochement avec les
études de médecine
l'intégration universitaire de la
formation de sage-femme est une mesure
positive pour une meilleure appréhension
des relations avec la myriade d'acteurs
que les étudiants seront terminés à
côtoyer
idem pour la création du troisième cycle
qui leur conférera de solides
compétences et un statut pérenne de
docteur à Mayotte
la possibilité de combiner leur activité
professionnelle avec des activités
d'enseignement et de recherche est une
belle ambition mais qui ne doit pas se
traduire par des pertes de revenus tant
nous connaissons la grande précarité
subie par les doctorats en France
par ailleurs ces avancées notables ne
doivent pas nous faire oublier les
alertes liées aux difficultés de
recrutement
en effet cela a été dit à maintes
reprises la profession vient une
véritable pénurie de main d'oeuvre
générale les explications sont plus
réelles et non identifie notamment celle
du syndrome d'épuisement professionnel
qui trouve son origine à la surcharge de
travail
à outre les sages-femmes constatent une
extension de leurs attributions tandis
que les horaires eux ne sont pas
extensibles dès qu'il y a une tâche
supplémentaire à réaliser en raison de
l'absence d'un collègue secrétaire
aide-soignant et autres c'est à nous de
l'assumer nous affirme l'une d'entre
elles sans compter bien d'autres
paramètres comme la relation étroite
qu'isé elle les entretiennent avec les
patientes et l'identification de
difficultés intra-familiales nécessitant
un accompagnement social de toute
urgence mais pas toujours opérationnel
en fonction de l'établissement
d'exercice
aussi et pour faire écho au débat
précédent sur la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle sur la protection de
l'IVG et de la contraception portée par
notre collègue Mélanie Vogel n'oublions
pas le rôle essentiel des sages-femmes
en matière de diffusion d'information
fiable et de soins de qualité envies
enfin malgré ces éléments de réflexion
annexes à la proposition de loi qui
devront inévitablement faire l'objet
d'une attention particulière à l'avenir
notre groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen votera à
l'unanimité à faveur de ce texte je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Bruno Belin pour le
groupe les républicains et pour 5
minutes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
madame la rapporteur
soutient total au texte évidemment et
notre collègue elle se Joseph tout à
l'heure a rappelé la position du groupe
en rappelant l'historique la nécessité
de faire évoluer cette profession et
donc vraiment soutien total mais trois
vérités trois vérités d'abord une
nécessité nécessité parce que le volume
des compétences exigeait sage-femme a
évidemment augmenté depuis la dernière
réforme du statut de formation qui doit
dater 2011 augmenter je pense notamment
à l'entretien
postnatal précoche je pense au
quadrillandrier de vaccination qui a
fortement augmenté je pense à des sujets
comme l'endométriose sujet totalement dû
il y a encore quelques années et puis
évidemment on pourrait penser au recours
croissants sur les besoins de lutte
contre un certain nombre d'addictologie
donc première vérité madame la mamie
c'est cette nécessité
d'une année supplémentaire
il y a une deuxième vérité c'est la
réalité la réalité risque d'être le
manque parce que là encore nous manquons
de sage-femme et nous manquons là encore
de candidats dans les écoles la réalité
du numérique s'appertus c'est j'en ai je
rabâche j'en ai parlé hier mais c'est
que pour l'instant on voit pas comment
ça va apporter une solution sur un
certain nombre de manques de
professionnels de santé
dont celui de sage-femme ça c'est une
réalité criante la gynécologie libérale
manque sur plus d'une dizaine de
départements manque totalement surpris
d'une dizaine de départements en France
le nombre de sages-femmes est quasiment
inexistant en milieu rural en milieu
libéral et puis on voit même arriver
j'ai pas entendu dans le débat un
certain nombre de péri professionnel je
pense à des coachings en natalité ou
des douleurs qu'on voit apparaître ici
là et là moi quand je vois apparaître ça
je me dis confiance et donc cette
deuxième vérité c'est cette réalité de
terrain qui fait que l'on doit
effectivement
professionnaliser augmenter le volume de
sage-femme en France
il y a une troisième vérité c'est
évidemment l'urgence
l'urgence de
professionnels valoriser le statut parce
que si effectivement on n'en veut plus
il faut valoriser ce statut je vous
rappelle et ça peut être dit dans les
disparités de Laurence Cohen à tout à
l'heure parler des questions de salaire
mais vous savez qu'il y a une disparité
forte chez sage-femme entre
fonction publique quand elles sont par
exemple dans un conseil départemental
Dans une PMI ou en milieu hospitalier
c'est à dire fonction publique
hospitalière on n'a pas les mêmes
grilles de salaire donc si on veut
promouvoir cette profession va falloir
un moment donné mettre tout le monde à
la même échelle ça c'est effectivement
une des urgences l'autre des urgences
c'est que votre gouvernement madame la
ministre vraiment ça fait 15 ans qu'on
parle des déserts médicaux vous le savez
comme moi on vit le sujet ayant le
connaît par cœur donc à un moment donné
quand est-ce qu'on se met à apporter des
réponses concrètes pour que on pallie à
toutes ces carences de professionnels de
santé sur les territoires moi je crois
que celui la compétence de partage de
tâches entendez bien ça à ma mamie parce
que va falloir un moment donné arrêtez
d'être en tuyau d'ordres que partage de
tâches et notamment avec les IPA avec
les sages-femmes avec les pharmaciens
puissent permettre d'apporter des
réponses donc c'est un texte que l'on
soutient c'est parce que c'est un
message évidemment de soutien à la
profession de sage-femme que l'on
apporte en votant ce texte ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
discussion générale et close madame la
ministre vous souhaitez prendre la
parole
merci Madame président tout d'abord
madame la rapporteur vous remercie
d'avoir porté ce texte saluer l'autrice
du texte
à Nice chapelier présente la présidente
de l'Ordre aussi présente et apporter
peut-être une réponse à certains d'entre
vous notamment sur évidemment il y avait
urgence à reconnaître
le métier des sages-femmes c'est
aujourd'hui chose faite maintenant
charges texte de continuer sa vie
parlementaire et compter sur moi pour
veiller à ce que ils puissent j'allais
dire arriver à l'Assemblée nationale et
être et être votée et vous dire à quel
point le gouvernement se mobilise
puisque la dernière orateur vous avez
fait allusion à la capacité à travailler
des sages-femmes à travailler avec les
autres professionnels de santé je vous
rappelle que il y a une semaine jour
pour jour les sept ordres et pas les
trois les 7 oui je sais qu'il est là
mais je regarde je sais qu'il est là les
sept ordres professionnels ont signé
j'allais dire un texte qui permet à tous
les professionnels de pouvoir travailler
ensemble et bien sûr puisque les
sages-femmes ont un ordre elles ont fait
partie de de signataires et elles seront
avec les pharmaciens les pédicure
polluques les dentistes les infirmiers
aux côtés et les pharmaciens les
expéditeurs podologues les dentistes les
infirmiers ils m'ont manquent les
sages-femmes et les kinés aux côtés des
médecins pour apporter des réponses et
dégager du temps de médical voilà vous
avez fait une demande c'est déjà exaucé
nous maintenant nous allons travailler
sur ce principe
merci madame la ministre nous passons la
discussion du texte de la commission
alors je vais mettre aux voix l'article
premier qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient donc
adopté je mets au voile article 1er bis
qui est pour
qui est contre qui
s'abstienté je me vois l'article 2 même
vote merci donc voilà l'article 3 même
vote
mais au voilà l'article 4 même vote
je me vois dans l'article 5 il est
supprimé excusez-moi ça va trop vite en
fait je vais mettre hautvois l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi monsieur Burgoa
merci Madame bien sûr je voterai ce
texte mais à mon tour je souhaitais
rendre hommage et félicité
à Nice chapelier qui était à
l'initiative de ces propositions qui a
été député du garde 2017 à 2022 donc
comprenez qu'entre parlementaires et une
solidarité
départementale lui dire que ce soir elle
peut être fière du travail qu'elle a
fait dans ce domaine là et lui dire avec
un petit clin d'oeil il y a quelques
kilomètres que ce soir elle pourra dire
que être parlementaire ça sert à quelque
chose parce que sa PPL avance et je suis
sûr que après les propos de Madame la
Ministre elle sera inscrite en deuxième
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale et que
la PPL deviendra loi et ça sera la loi
en échappeler
merci merci chers collègues
alors je mets aux voix l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi visant à faire
évoluer la formation de sage-femme qui
est pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté à unanimité
madame la présidente Catherine de roche
bien entendu
très rapidement pour remercier d'avoir
Raymond de penser sur le groupe d'avoir
inscrit ce texte et la remercier de
d'avoir apporté ce texte en y apportant
cette modification importante c'était
mis d'accord avec l'ordre et avec les
étudiantes sur le délai donc je salue en
effet la présidente de l'Ordre je salue
les associations
d'étudiants sage-femme et bien
évidemment
à Annie chapelier qui verra qui verra
son texte alors je sais que pour
certains points vous souhaitez aller un
petit peu plus loin mais qui vaut mieux
tenir que courir et nous sommes
importants déjà de cranter quand est-ce
qui a été mis dans le texte et
maintenant madame la ministre il n'y a
plus qu'un inscrire très vite à
l'Assemblée nationale de l'adopter
conforme à l'Assemblée nationale et
voilà le texte sera définitif
merci madame la Présidente alors mes
chers collègues je vais lever la séance
et prochaine séance le jeudi 20 octobre
à 10h30 pour l'examen de la proposition
de loi créant une aide universelle
d'urgence pour les victimes de violences
conjugales la séance est levée